citizens of the reject Nation we are
here to continue the coast Rider
franchise with spirit of Vengeance yeah
how are you I'm good how are you I'm
doing good we have never seen this movie
guys if you didn't catch Tara's first
time watching and my first time
re-watching in like 20 years or whatever
the first one came out that is up here
on the channel now we get to experience
this together I hear this one is weird
weird I have seen a couple of the movies
these directors have made have you seen
the crank movies yes it's these guys
okay so we might be a little okay if
you've seen them that gives us a little
bit of leeway to be a tad prepared for
the kind of style I don't know if I've
seen the entire movie Crank but I have
seen a scene that stuck in my head like
crank came out in like 2005 right like
it's old movie yeah okay then I think
I've seen some of it but not the whole
thing and yes okay I'm with the vibe now
let's do it so guys leave a like that
would be very much appreciated also ring
the bell
ring the bell ring the bell ring it and
also uh full length Direction watch
along where you sync with your own copy
of spirit of Vengeance available for
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
muchas gracias to all who have joined
our patreon page thus far and uh cover
several things exclusive over there with
highlights and watch Longs included
let's get to it rejack Nation
[Music]
there's that frenetic energy
are those monks
that's it yourself I did not know he was
in this the Devil Himself was
one place that is safe that is the
sanctuary in a few days the winter
solstice will be passed and with it the
hour of the prophecy and the boy will
give no use to anyone oh it's the guy
from Buffy they both work together in a
TV show and I don't know the name
wow
[Applause]
to hell
so there's they're after a boy
[Music]
oh
I can help you
he's trying to help you I must take you
to the ghost
whoa that was a cool shot where are they
shut up
what that guy was barely in this room
[Music]
[Laughter]
some cool shots in here
what okay
that's like a video game
nice shot bro
[Music]
oh that's awesome my name is Johnny
Blairs
yeah you see my motorcycle for a living
I did a bare ass 360 triple back flip in
front of 22 000 people this is like
spider-verse yeah but when my dad got
sick I did something way crazier than
that
you look like you could use a little
help are you willing to
they're redoing the origin wow yeah or
save his life
I'm the guy who made the deal with
possessed by an ancient demon and I pray
on the wicked I love these visuals I try
to find it but the darkness inside me
only gets stronger that's why I had to
run this is cool man
and I'm still running that's an awesome
intro where's Roxanne
my brothers are dead as should I be if
not for the intervention of God
oh my God
[Laughter]
saved by a tree
it likes the Dark Places I don't know
what you're talking about oh no it's
taking over his just Johnny Blaze life
oh why are you here
I need your help and you need your soul
so we make a deal we know about making
deals don't you Johnny oh he does I mean
the devil now you no problem you who's
Evian
I know
save
people
what brought you out here thousands of
miles from your place of birth and your
dark rebirth
this wait is a shot is so kinetic
this man that you met years ago that put
the curse on you yeah link that connects
you to this child bring us the boy and
we will lift your curse oh no you don't
want that we don't want that
what's up
what the hell
whoa that
is demented
cool shot
look I got people after Danny and me so
just let me go I'm the people
this guy's a prick seems like a real
slimy jerk
oh my God all right
you're just gonna like oh my God to it
kid stop that kid's face yeah to a kid
Let's Ride
heck yeah
yeah whoa this is a there's some really
cool shots in this man
ready
whoa
oh he already looks way more rad yeah
it's more hellish
yeah I was like what do we do
nicely dude
I like how it actually looks like a
skull that yeah burnt to a crisp it
looks like real yeah
what just happened
[Music]
he's really taking his time this Johnny
Blaze look at it
yeah is he singing all the bad history
soul sucking right now oh my God is his
head gonna explode
[Music]
wow it did
oh did the little boy do that I think
the little boy did that
really
yeah with his drop of blood
oh okay that worked a little bit get
some
stuff
get him in the car he's like protecting
the boy now
yo Ghost Rider what happened back there
yeah come on man it's been way too much
time just just milking it melting that
guy's brain when really you just could
have like turned him to Ash real quick
look at this
although they just treat this little kid
like [__] it's like so much kids deserve
it I got your package but the guys are
doing business with me just went up we
had an agreement Carrigan changing the
defined terms of agreement is something
we just don't do that looks like a young
Kurt Russell yes
thank you that was bothering me three of
my guys got turned into matchsticks last
night by a dude on a motorcycle with his
head on fire come again I've seen things
weird things bad things
that's a cool transition what I want you
very closely
Kill Them All
[Music]
I just uploaded a little program
firewall a friend on the motorcycle
won't be able to sense him now that
explains for me
this movie isn't like disorienting or
nauseating it looks really cool yeah it
looks dope flip flops between like so
many times like two this is really
awesome
so many camera angles
you tracked us
why you do it again I could feel them
before I could sense them and then
nothing
no no he's not dead he's just blocked
off it's like a firewall he's offline
man
when Nick is like just free roaming
crazy path
that's when he found me you promised to
take the pain away but he asked for
something in return you're the devil's
baby mama huh hell yeah why does the
devil walk on earth in human form anyway
maybe just passes on from body to body
down through history waiting for the
perfect fit
oh my God
on Earth he's weak his powers are
limited he needs emissaries to do his
dirty work so he finds them or makes
them using his greatest power handshake
the deal yeah
AKA a handshake the power of a handshake
can I open a window do you think you can
just talk you know your mom thought she
could just talk until I could go Gypsy
faces it's just a window yeah I mean
definitely time for these guys to die
yeah kid
oh damn oh all right it's a good thing
he buckled up that ensures are gonna be
just fine safety
thank you
so dark and gritty
I don't know dude what happened
yeah
oh
what do they do to those other guys yeah
why do we get to see them kill them man
that's the guy it looks like it works on
a cruise ship
[Music]
I got it this is like drugged out so
high right now
long time idea you look good oh
he's so on edge I love it last couple of
days and a few hours ago whoa oh whoa
all right John
oh my goodness for you and the rider is
me he's just
whoa he's gripping at the door
I'm gonna let him out
this is awesome
together I know the place John
gotta go we gotta go
yeah
I am all here for Nicolas Cage's dude oh
my gosh me too here for it
it's all right thank you cool cool shot
oh my goodness
oh my God
this looks like a metal music video yeah
oh yeah
I just love how unstable he is he's off
his rocker man this one feels like it
could be R-rated yeah and why is it
PG-13 yeah
I'm sorry I'm gonna get you out of here
just try kissing her making out real
quick before he kills her
oh
all right
smart so I always bring a gun to a knife
fight give me that thing give it to me
what the tracker missile
laughs
like Harry's like a monster
oh [__] oh
what
what what is he doing how where did he
learn that
just eating bullets oh my God he's gonna
barf him up awesome
oh that backfired
oh [__] that's rad
what did he just convert this whole
thing
I love it I love it this is like
nightmare fuel
[Music]
holy [__]
nice how does this guy keep surviving I
mean this is when you start running away
from him because you oh what I yeah a
hands gun is gonna do it now
just kill him Ghost Rider yeah come on
just do it we all know he won't though I
really feel like you really get the
sense of Nicholas Cage playing the Ghost
Rider this time yeah yeah
don't hurt her what
what it's like split personalities Let
Her Go
oh damn he was supposed to save him but
he's the new enemy oh my gosh is he like
his arch nemesis now
that happened what
happened to be
I thought I was gonna
sting your face
[Laughter]
so what's next well morose seems to
think that the days will pass in a few
days if we could just get Danny
someplace safe I've already contacted
Monroe he's going to catch up with us on
the road
road
you're not done Carrie again yeah be
kidding me
no way
oh he knows how to
huh
what the hell's going on
oh what oh what Reborn
who how when why
oh my God he looks terrifying feral
oh
so he lost a little bit of Decay power
giving it to him because I mean he looks
messed up now
is it anything he touches
whoa that looks awesome the machine you
made it change
that's how it works whenever he rides
changes with him hey what if you have to
pee while you're on fire huh that's
awesome it's like a flamethrower you
know it's like
oh my God that was that was so dumb oh
my God that's great what is this
this power that we have comes from a
dark place but it's not who we are and
we can use it to do good like I'm
helping you and your mom
I know why you're helping us so
Disturbed she says you want to get rid
of it
you want to have some fun
[Music]
why not
hang on
whoa
[Music]
there are some cool bike stunts
[Applause]
this is so strange
I'm here for it the weirder it gets the
better yeah well is he toasting in the
cup yeah oh I got it I love it how can
he drive but he can't touch bread what
are the rules here to the decay
amen he looks familiar
you mustn't be afraid it was God that
led you here that's Christopher Lambert
have you seen Mortal Kombat yeah he's
raid in Highlander
oh I couldn't see him through all the
tats you're safe
I'm sure that will never happen the
exposure in this Scene It seems highly
filtered
what is it staying inside
him it was an angel
a spirit of Justice are we redoing the
origin of just rewriting it brought down
to Hell
corrupted
well driven in sand experimental he
became the spirit of versions
but the angel
Spirit of Justice
he's alive in there you could awaken him
you must confess
the one thing that is most difficult for
you to talk about his dad my dad
went into it for him
I couldn't let him go
it was selfish I'm sorry I'm full of
tears
this
is the Lamb of God the bread of Christ
we are those that are called to receive
him you say that you are not worthy to
receive him I'm not
oh that's great
that's delicious
been carrying this bread around
they cannot follow
are you ready
oh no is this tomb where Jesus was
buried and on the third day he rose
again Greg is it Easter yet
[Music]
is this like an exorcism
he's exercising it out what
okay
so
so depraved this movie's tiring me out
man
once the ringer with this movie
boxing match
[Laughter]
we're both gonna need a nap after this
get back
you need to welcome the spirit of
Vengeance back in you
what will be done
they gotta get rid of the devil we got
to hold the boy until the danger passes
this boy exists
power always be inside him this child
must be destroyed
nah man
what are they gonna chop off his head
little boy use your powers my goodness
yeah have him machete all the guys
around you all their heads come off
yeah
cool
oh uh good thing Decay guys here
what a cruel way to die
whoa
oh God
wow oh that's gnarly
whoa look at how they look
I look like statues
ah the juxtaposition of life and death
yeah so now he's with Rorke some
protectors you turned out to be what
exactly does Rog have in mind the child
must be in his 13th year before the red
can be performed on the dawn of a new
winter the right what does that mean
Rock father the boy is a vessel as a
container for his power the ritual will
transform his Essence his soul into the
boy
do you know where work has them I think
so yes well by so now you want to play
Hero but I promise Danny he'd be safe
and if I walk away now I'm just trading
one demon for another
it's gonna do without the writer there's
no way he's got to go back in the Tomb
and like get it back right he can't just
be rolling in him and Nick Cage in it
Danny
do you know who I am
I love this guy who's there that is
where the ritual is to take place so I
think we should have
weapons
sweet oh cool cool holy people his body
I'm living in it's weak but you
at Orioles
can wield the power without burning
itself up I like his performance yeah
slimy and creepy who are they
politicians murderers people of
influence
the devil's soldiers
look at this Sound Stage
Danny's soul will be lost forever at the
break of dawn
I've made a lot of mistakes place
Danny's one good thing I ever did he's
the son of the devil hey hang it in
there Tara I was just thinking like if
she had him and the devil's baby doesn't
she still have a little bit of devil in
her and she could use it to her power
like
it's a good theory
what about you
not bad
might be good on a salad oh my God
[Music]
what's a waste of good wine
he's just gonna grab him from there
uh
uh freaky
come on
oh fight it
oh no no oh
it's too easy he's gonna race you Danny
whoa
uh that can still see the light
[Music]
oh whoa damn cool you're nothing but an
insect food for the Mills of hell
gosh that looked it looked like just
just a hand yeah oh man how can he get
his power back this is not
for
my powers and years are the same
you said
gonna give him the Ghost Rider powers
do it
oh wow
oh my gosh
[Music]
heck yeah he's back baby
oh [__]
gotta War Maneuvers right there
okay
oh man he doesn't cut through the
asphalt anymore it's cool seeing this in
the daytime
[Music]
oh his face looks insane
cool
Wilhelm so if you just jump and scream
out of fear out of the truck I love how
you could just convert all these
vehicles fire truck
[Applause]
whoa
[Music]
this mother ah this guy start swerving
lady
at the Briggs kid real hard
come here
cool
[Music]
I like the shifting of perspectives
oh
[Applause]
unbelievable
oh
I was never afraid of you
[Music]
do the patents there
what it was that quick he just did it
what are you just roadkill oh my God
cool shot
[Music]
oh oh geez whoa you're gonna kill the
boy oh my God you yes I'm saving you
James a little boy you think that
through buddy they managed to pull off
these visuals during the daytime you
normally can't like to get Ghost Rider
in the day it's hard yeah
does a lot of screaming and faces
and deal ever made
go
oh
[Music]
my goodness right now
love it
all right
he's like a monster animal this time
like the jittery movement
the kids got to be still alive right
save money on the transformation
bro since the writer was an angel
that went crazy
healed
heal
yeah
now let him do it
give him some Angel juice oh snap that
was really much of a moment uh that was
very quick barely touched him yeah could
the angel even get in there that quick
did we win I'm gonna say yeah
hell yes
okay
my name is Johnny Blaze oh New Life
[Laughter]
the angel Ghost Rider now
wow
my eyes hurt
well if they're saying to watch
something
they're saying what if they're
suggesting another movie
that must mean that's no post credits
okay
oh wow my eyes hurt
uh-huh I feel like I need a cold press
yeah
that's one way to put it oh God
take it away Tara oh wow me first huh
yeah you go first Tara
I really liked it
um the style of like
I always think it's crazy how two
directors can work together find a style
like this with a DP and then an editor
who's like absolutely no know what to do
with all of this because you go from
like over the head shot to like dolly in
on somebody's face and then it's a
close-up but I'd like two frames to come
together and then go out and it's just
one wide frame but then it comes back
into a close-up like it's insane and
definitely is kind of made like one was
this made like into early 2000s like
it's kind of made for like today with
social media how nobody can like if the
shot doesn't change every seven seconds
this movie is
like re-release
release now on tick tock
will be like rather forever yeah
um I really liked it though I liked I
thought that he was going I thought he
was gonna have to go back in the Tomb
and like change back on his own volition
but uh I like that the kid gave him the
the power at the end it was rooted in
love yeah I like that uh
and also just Nick Cage's monologue gave
me so much joy when he is high on drugs
and he just gives that whole monologue
to that guy uh that just that made my
life yeah I would like that to play over
and over in the background on my TV when
I'm doing anything
I think the first movie
is overall in total
a better movie agreed because it's got
like
a real movie to it
it also has what's his nuts Who is
fantastic the guy that we kept saying
Yeah Yeah
but this doesn't feel like a sequel to
that movie at all no it's like they made
it it's like they made it their own they
like you were saying in the beginning
it's like they rewrote the even the
beginning that the origin story because
that first movie ends off on he's gonna
be a hero and he's gonna go after
Mephisto the devil and then here it's
like we're doing a completely separate
movie we're doing something entirely
different this time around and there's
things about this though that I that I
do prefer like a lot like not not even
like by a small margin I mean there's
things that aesthetically that I really
dug so much like whatever it was
um you know in Ghost Rider form the
visuals of that that kinetic frenzy
nature and it also like the texture to
it felt more real and tangible yeah
versus uh you know the first movie where
it did look like CGI white skull thing
yeah I like the aesthetic they went for
like it looked like a crisp skull like
the skull that was like it burned off
his flesh and this is this is his
skeleton nature of it
um and I thought there was a lot of
great visuals to it and especially with
the action scenes of like converting the
vehicles the many times yeah I I thought
there was a lot of really cool uh
orchestrated shots overall it's just
that what it wasn't with Ghost Rider or
Nick Cage
the pacing of It kind of weighed the
movie down for me a little bit like when
it was when it was Nick Cage it was so
fun it was such a blast and I was like I
might prefer this more just because of
like how crazy unhinged he is but you
spend like half the movie with these
other people who are kind of boring yeah
and uninteresting and at least with the
first movie you're mainly with Nicholas
Cage who's giving a very different
performance very different uh yeah like
and that one he's like I'm playing a
relatable hero yeah here he's like I'm
playing okay
that's so great
um so yeah I mean people set us up that
this is like oh man it's kind of not
good but I there's a lot about it that I
actually liked uh quite a bit and like
you I'm actually appreciative of of the
overall aesthetic and style and the
wackiness that this movie has to offer
yeah I I actually think that it was in
her it would fluctuate at times it was
like okay this is a bit tedious too this
is really engaging but it never stayed
only tedious right I never stayed only
engaging like it would it would dip in
and out literally from beginning to end
and in the shots too yeah it would be a
different thing if I was here going it'd
be a different thing if it was like oh
this is fun and then like the last half
is just right yeah yeah it just kept
flipping in and out uh throughout so
because of the fact that like at least
more than half of it was like fun and
weird in ways that were like I don't
know like him him peeing fire I'm like
it's so bizarre what but I like it also
Jerry Springer yeah oh with the
animation visuals those are amazing
those those provided a a really cool uh
life to it like the yeah the first one
plays it
safe in what it's going for like it's
well done and it's got a cool like PG-13
Supernatural Aura to it and this one
goes like so dark yeah and so more and
so Tower like it goes so dark to the
point that it kind of strips away some
of the fun
but at times the movie is really fun
yeah but it's like it's you're right
with like the the tone and the pacing of
like when there's jokes in there when
it's like uh what it was like roadkill
and then the the guy the guy that turned
his hair blonde yeah he said some funny
line on the ground I don't even remember
what it was but it was obviously meant
to be like a comedic line we're gonna
add in and I was like ah I don't know if
it feels like right now if that's gonna
work or if it should I was like oh
should they have just played it yeah in
that moment just seriously where I don't
know he's mad and he's his powers are
taken away I I forget the joke he made
so I'm not I'm not making a good point
Point here but you guys understand that
there's like times when that came up and
I was like I can laugh at it for sure I
just it wasn't like hahaha genuinely
funny to me because I kind of would get
wrapped up in the story of like where is
this actually going like is this is this
freaking guy like gonna die already the
the d uh decomposing decaying guy thank
you like when he came up in the
beginning that was a little bit when the
story slowed down I saw him once and
then when you continue to see him with
weapons and people and all of their guns
give me a bigger weapon round two and
you're like guys haven't you learned
your lesson like just get out of there
this guy you can't kill him uh it's just
funny to me that they they didn't think
to like add in I don't know a little bit
of a conversation of like he doesn't die
via weapons so can we try something else
like just skip to it like then somebody
else like sign a deal with the devil and
be like you gotta mess me up now forever
so I can kill the Ghost Rider yeah yeah
I think that they're never going to make
it okay 2012 is when this came out
they're never again they're never going
to make it but the perfect film would
have been a part three that is a hybrid
of the first one yes and this one like
amazing yeah something that goes for the
incredibly dark manic bleakness
craziness but also manages to be a real
movie yeah it manages to be like have
because the relationships in the first
one are better I believed them more I
felt it more there was more of a heart
yeah to it but it also does play it like
Ghost Riders superhero you know like we
don't wanna we don't want to cry whereas
I liked how like
um malevolent and and
um a freaking crazy unhinged the actual
Ghost Rider is like yeah he really is
this deranged monster and I like this
soul that they gave him here like
there's that how it was uh and Angel who
got corrupted and like they did like
experimental torture to him and it's a
so it's an angel who was corrupted not
because it was tempted by evil but was
tortured you know yeah I I like how they
captures that tortured spirit and I I
feel like the Ghost Rider and the first
one could have been played by I'm not
talking about Johnny Blaze I'm talking
about the ghost writer itself could have
been played by anyone like any stun
double or mocap actor yes where here I
really got the sense that it was Nick
Cage doing it yeah like you could feel
Nick Cage in the performance so I I like
it and I prefer the Johnny overall I
actually prefer this Johnny Blaze who is
who is just so like intense yeah yeah
like it's it's such a he's uncomfortable
in his own skin in every moment I I like
that uh so that's what I mean there's a
lot about this that I actually prefer
that I that I enjoyed and I think the
perfect movie would have been some blend
of what the first one was doing with
this one uh yeah and to get is Sam
Elliott him to fight together what in
the F like I still think about that all
the time I'm like I wish I could see
that fight they really dropped like a
lot of like the Penance there yeah yeah
that's such a big thing in the first one
yeah to the point where it actually
feels like they dialed back some of the
Ghost Rider's Powers here you know what
I mean yes right right yeah it's it's
except they bumped him up with like the
visual and I think in in making this
like when you said you're like how do
they storyboard this so I'm like yeah
they must have had to like be like we
need a million animators to like draw
this out to make it look insane
um but specifically to make the Ghost
Rider more tangible like uh more
palpable like just when you look at him
you're like heck yeah like I am on board
with it
um and all of the visuals were really
really awesome but I do agree it was
missing a little bit of the heart no
matter how hard they tried to like that
one moment where they're like let's just
have the kid at the diner look at
another kid with his dad and have Nick
Cage notice it and then wipe try to wipe
his hair with the same like I'm like
what Nick I I don't I was like this
seems like a forced moment can there be
anything written a little bit better
that wasn't like oh there was a bee in
your hair you couldn't feel it like some
crazy bike stuff like what yeah like
that didn't it it was it was obvious
what they were trying to do but it
wasn't delivered in the in the right way
for me to feel it well the movie doesn't
breathe yeah it's just this it once the
engine starts it is pretty much this one
pace throughout and and every scene that
needs a moment to just really like slow
down and breathe yeah because I'm all
for the style when it was doing the
action scenes but it needed to breathe
for like emotional momency yes so you
could get attached to something because
I was like I don't feel any Stakes
happening here despite the fact that I
am enjoying what is before both like
right holding my eyes right now you know
yeah so yeah it was it was uh it was a
fascinating experience I agree overall
though yeah no room's fun it was fun
it's a lot of fun it was fun but but it
was like my eyeballs are kind of hurting
now yeah because because there's nothing
happening in my heart right now other
than when I'm laughing with something
that's cool that's happening but there
was there were some genuinely cool stuff
here but it sucks we'll never get a part
three yeah I feel like that's why I
didn't like the whole movie I had I
couldn't say anything I just was like
I was like that like mouth a gap Agape
however people say it and just staring
at this green the entire time like I
don't I was very engulfed in like what
is gonna happen next because the screen
is always changing but I'm like I was
really like when are they gonna oh it's
gonna come don't miss a cut because you
never know you could miss him turning
into the angel in a second
um but I did like you said the devil guy
at the very end if he would have been
more throughout this movie even though
he was there but it was only touches of
him it was more the other decaying guy
that I thought the devil was he's a
great actor I forget his name but like
he he was great and and very very
believable in that that maybe I don't
know it would it wouldn't have felt as
tedious if maybe he was more in it and
we didn't cut back to them trying so
much to kill him the same way with like
bullets and cannons yeah that they would
have tried a different technique like
just show us something different that
you've used like your brain and your
weird devil powers like the decaying
thing is cool like great I gave you
Powers see what you can do now cool got
it
um it just took us a little while to get
there I think of them trying the same
way to kill him and I I just thought man
there's got to be
something more creative here especially
with the way the there it's animated the
way that it's cut and edited that they
weren't like let's just play with
something else like how else could we
kill him that doesn't have to do with
like
um like I don't know I'd be like I'm
gonna fly a helicopter and see if the
blades can like cut off his head like I
don't this seems like that movie that
would try something like that like uh
instead of guns and cannons and all that
yes there's no Stakes when you're doing
guns against Ghost Rider right like you
just like come on guys
yeah yeah I like but what about like
drowning him or like like weird stuff
yeah right well when he does kill them
with like the chain I love the look in
this so awesome it's like yes I know you
haven't played God of War but it is like
it is kind of like a video game where
it's just the way the the the the
efficiency the swiftness oh yeah so cool
but they're also like this it's striking
yeah yeah it looked really beautiful at
the very end when he killed kills all of
the monks not that killing the monks
looks beautiful but there is a shot from
up above and he takes the chain and it's
like goes through the whole crowd of
them that looked awesome like a piece of
art artwork yeah yeah uh but movie
definitely needed some uh a little heart
a heart and I like Idris Elba overall
yeah I mean I always love it yourself in
anything isn't it I love how he just
looks like Idris Elba and how and like
even his costume is like how he dresses
in like every other movie yeah except he
just has a different accent this time
yeah what was his accent and he had
contacts on I don't know what his accent
was it was like German French I don't
know maybe
I don't know it was when he started
talking at first I was like oh okay
we're doing the accent thing here
definitely picking it out of that
accident yeah that's that was the thing
where I was like why are we doing this
and not just having him yeah just
talking to me his regular voice which is
already an accent but I don't think he
was like Superstar at rusalba the way he
is now
no he was very much secondary character
but what's funny to me is that the guy
that dies first and we're like oh we
like that guy the priest guy that was
with it in Buffy yes but I know and you
guys can leave it in the comments or
something yes they darn they in that
show together Luther I've never seen
Luther I think they're in that show
together I haven't seen the whole thing
I think I watched like a season in my
memory sucks but I think that guy and
Idris Elba work together all the time on
a TV series which I thought it's cool
because I'm like was this the first time
they met on Ghost Rider 2 and now
they're working together a lot more or
am I just insane and I made that up I
don't know
you guys can let me know
the last thing I think the sets could
have been better
so like low budget oh interesting yeah
except the visuals looked [__]
expensive as [__] yes but were they shot
everything just seemed like the most
empty Landscapes yeah you're you're that
you look like a fan like where you would
shoot on location for a fan film yes you
know exactly that's why I was like when
you're like where are they I was like
Star Wars it looked like a like you know
the red Rocky like but with nothing
around it though like the it's like
before set deck got there and they were
like well we're gonna start with this
and then they were like yeah we're gonna
just We're not gonna do anything else
just we're gonna like if there was
actual holes in the like in the canyons
or whatever I was like I think that's
like probably all fake but yes it was it
wasn't as interesting which you think
that they would have put I guess more
like effort into it but were they just
going along with like no it's this is
where the monks live there's nothing
around here like they're not supposed to
it's not supposed to be cool right I'm
curious to see what the budget is I
wonder if part of the deal was like we
can bring this budget down oh okay let's
compare it Ghost Rider one production
budget what is the Ghost Rider one okay
okay 110 million dollar budget for the
first one okay Ghost Rider spirit of
Vengeance
production budget
oh they cut it down by like 50 million
dollars yeah
it definitely shows though like wow
yeah definitely yes it was a lot of like
Street stuff same location Cliffs and
then it really is monk stuff it looked
very cheap were they shot I guess you're
right yeah I kind of wasn't registering
it because they uh I guess they did a
good job with just I mean cutting around
it like when they're not lot with a
bunch of rocks and then he takes the
tractor and that's the first time we
finally get to see the tractor go on
fire and that's obviously all slightly
animated CGI whatever but it looked
awesome but yeah I get you can
definitely do that with a cheaper like
location
well cheap is good I suppose I wonder if
the movie made its money back still did
the gig still did the Jab
radio people will listen leave your
nitpicks down below yeah man that's what
we ask you to do today Tara RX and thank
you so much for being here thank you so
much Greg Alba I said his name right I
tried to do it wrong
leave your thoughts down below did you
like this one or did you hate it
um subscribe click that Bell leave a
like follow Tara Rixon on go tub
let's end this with a patron of the day
shout out let's do it Lance door Lance
is the perfect person to shout out okay
Ghost Rider because he's a firefighter
now imagine if you gave
firefighter like Lance store the powers
of Ghost Rider he would show up put the
fires out and then before you know it he
sets the whole place on fire yes brand
new fire I like that all over again well
you know that the best way to fight fire
though Gregory is with fire and bullets
yeah have you ever shot a fire it was
right out they gonna get scared it goes
right through it yeah I'm gonna die it
goes straight to hell it goes straight
to hell you said the three send the
bullets so Lance you are the newly
chosen appointed spirit of Vengeance
today buddy wow lucky guy you're gonna
go out there you're gonna ride your
motorcycle to that next fire to put it
out only to create an even bigger firing
chaos soon you'll be fired haha fire man
who's on fire who gets fired then you'll
have to be on the run then you'll go
crazy just like Nick Cage here because
you will be unemployed yeah and also on
fire and also constantly on fire because
you can't seem to put then next thing
you know you got bills to pay you got to
put out fires in your personal life you
lost your house you get a divorce your
kids are like my dad's on fire all the
time skip it you know what I mean it's
tough it's tough living but I think you
can handle it door oh your life will be
physically and metaphorically on fire at
all times but you know what will not be
on fire your career it'll be drowning
so Lance thanks for being part of the
patreon page happy to have you here
again you had another month buddy
[Music]